d'accord sont en général à un héritage
de l'urbanisation coloniale qui favorise
et les voies de communication pour
l'exportation des ressources aujourd'hui
il est à constater que cette
urbanisation n'est pas adapté aux
réalités locales d'où la nécessité de
réinventer nos vieillards en prenant
compte des réalités locales et surtout
se baser sur notre identité notre
patrimoine culturel afin de bâtir des
villes que nous le sommes nous pas
passer directement des plans à la
réalité mais plutôt de la réalité au
plan je suis innocent nous est narrée je
veux vous présenter notre projet qui
consiste à inventer la ville de dakar
dak'art de fener dakar se doute qu'on
peut dire pas et c'est magique nommée
label ses phrases résument en quelque
sorte la mentalité état d'esprit de ses
différentes vies donc la manière
d'organiser la ville de paris ne devrait
pas être la même manière d'organiser la
ville de dakar a eu sur l'eau mais parle
d'un coeur se faire coucou aux bons
plats lüthi 12e de la tat parler le
dakar s'est rendu telle atteint enfin me
d'arrêt de dunkerque et des cafés comme
à chaque point de dakar c'est prend le
car a pu aller aux mamelles profiter de
la plage tous ces éléments font partie
de l'identité de la ville de dakar d'un
quart à évoluer compte aujourd'hui une
densité de plus de 16 mille habitants
par kilomètre carré son centre ville qui
est dakar plateau pour un jeu souvent
plus de 300000 personnes pas ou qui
vivent en cui travailler et cela
occasionnera des nombreux vols notamment
des problèmes de circulation de canal a
sion et autres suite à cela mon équipe
et moi avons fait une immersion sur le
site vous faire une analyse approfondie
dont les grands prix sont les suivants
le manque de végétation
il n'y a pas assez de points vers midi
une bombe pour favoriser la marche à
pied pas de mixité des fonctions
on y retrouve peu de loyers et beaucoup
de bâtiments à fonction économie
politique et résidentiel une mobilité
très réduite le centre ville souffre de
problèmes de stationnement
d'embouteillage et de l'occupation
anarchique des trottoirs par des
marchands un problème de garde à lille
dakar-plateau regorge d'îlots de chaleur
et les îlots de fraîcheur sont là au vu
de tous ces problèmes nous proposons des
interventions qui transformeront dakar
plateau dans un quartier qui favorise
les transports en commun et les
déplacements non motorisés avec des
parcs jardins partagés et des
équipements mixte qui active la vue à
des différentes heures de la journée
tout en préservant l'aspect cultuel de
centre ville de dakar nous souhaitons
également promouvoir les secteurs locaux
tels que l'agriculture
la logistique et station de recyclage
une énergie propre et renouvelable est
visé et tous les efforts sont faits pour
le jure les émissions de carbone avec
des plans de gestion méticuleux de
l'énergie de l'eau des déchets et de la
revégétalisation notre projet prévoit
également l'aménagement des espaces
verts pour créer un poumon vert et sur
le long terme la transformation du port
de dakar en un port de plaisance des
jardins privés en jardins partagés ainsi
que l'aménagement des kiosques citoyens
pour favoriser la mixité des fonctions
les étapes nécessaires à la réussite
d'un tel projet sur et la mise en place
de panneaux solaires dans la quasi
totalité des bâtiments à usage public et
privé la végétalisation des toitures et
la pose des façades double pour limiter
le rayonnement direct sur les façades la
réhabilitation complète du site par la
diminution des stationnements et l'ajout
des espaces publics comprenant des
espaces verts et parkings à vélos et des
pistes cyclables
c'était mon saint jean pour le décor
merci